science experiment gone wrong from
things that are doing in space hit
earthing experiment affects a few
animals the gorilla is one of them
Dwayne Johnson the rock is what is he
here something yes he loves gorillas so
he wants to look like works out so you
know he's this guy you know who's a
former soldier who doesn't do well with
people this gorilla was almost like his
little child
the thing about Dwayne Johnson as a
performer to me is like no matter what
backstory you give him he always has the
same level of charisma you're the most
well-adjusted introverted hey reject
nation we're just three friends hanging
out in the couch we want to talk about a
Duany Johnson movie rampage from hi this
is Courtney Scott right follow her on
Instagram and Twitter that's John
Humphrey still I'm Jack away thank you
I always like this w had a charm but the
beards better normally what we do for
our movie reviews as we break them down
and reason to see and reasons not to see
but because there's three of us it's a
non spoiler that would just be way too
complicated for three people to get all
in the same page about everything so
just gonna be a free-flowing review
today how about we kick it off like this
for just general overall opinions there
are Stardust reactions for you guys hi I
just saw rampage and really
and I gotta say it made the movie for me
watching that and all the creatures in
all their glory was fantastic and I
highly recommend this film it was a
great time you're gonna love it all
right if you guys have seen a trailer
for this movie and you wanted to see a
charming Rock bomb with a charming white
monkey and also have some awesome
monster action this movie gives you what
you're expecting and what you're looking
forward to and you got to commend it for
that while there are some flaws and that
you know we could definitely touch on at
the end of the day waiter going in for
you're gonna get it's a live action
cartoon and if you're into that kind of
thing you'll probably have fun so you
know 3d so 3d RealD really so Courtney
apparently might have liked it more than
us what was your like that core anyway
how do you feel about the moon we had a
great time it was a lot of fun for video
game movie I thought it was very well
done a lot of times video game movies
just kind of fall flat on all levels but
I like the writing the acting the
monsters at the end of the day when you
watch the trailers for this movie
you go in there going what do I care
about I want to see a charming Dwayne
Johnson I want to see some cool monster
action you get that and any day you do
get that there's just a lot of things in
between
I just don't like I think would surprise
me about the film in a really positive
way was how much I cared about his
relationship with the main gorilla
George yeah the white gorilla racist
right am i right
how by no it's had to make him a white
whale he's interacting with this CGI
gorilla what sells it is his performance
that CGI and all the everything done
with the gorilla sells it to but as the
human character who has to really
believe he's interacting with this
gorilla he really sells it things start
happening - Georgeann you starts getting
bigger and gets more rageful and he's
getting hurt by it and he really cares
he just wants to protect his friend he
keeps calling it a friend not an animal
that level of concern I'm not feeling
that all within the first half of the
movie I care about the situation at hand
yeah he really did a good job of
creating a persona for this gorilla you
know he did use the word friend
I think sign language helped him yeah
because if you are just acting with like
a yellow tennis ball if you're still
doing the sign language it connects you
in a way I think that's different then
you're just actually talking to it and
imagining that it's there and there's
some cool monster action in here too
yet what two other monsters yeah George
Ralph and Lizzy man yeah got the wolf
and the Gators yeah midway games in fact
at one point in the movie they do the
name wolf Ralph
they never do they don't explain that I
didn't even realize let's just hang onto
the game to me the first half of this
movie is significantly better with the
giant wolf there's a really cool
sequence that they do there there's a
point around act 2 and then through most
of act 2 where I was really checking out
and was rather bored maybe you're
leaving a little bit earlier you spend
way less time with the the monsters the
giant animal you spend way less time
with them it's a lot of humans and I
just thought a lot of that was really
dull whenever they try being more than a
cheesy movie is when I thought this
movie started lacking because I thought
that tones yeah I'm feeling we were
gonna have like our disagreement is that
I thought the tone was inconsistent it
seemed like there were times where the
director knew what he was making and
then there were times where I felt like
that people were unintentionally
laughing at the movie I did find both
kinds of webs yeah because I felt like
each set of human characters was kind of
in a different movie at different tones
some of them managed a little better
than others but yeah there were times
when I was like this seems a little bit
too silly or this is trying to sell me
something serious that I don't believe
when you know the film wants you to
start taking it a little more serious is
when I couldn't buy it I guess that is
what helps me kind of buy into it that's
fair yeah this opinions are subjective
what is your wiser I wonder that gave it
a step up above a regular video game
they did try to create something in
order to give the audience in actual
movie as opposed to just
some animals that are really tall
against the building I heard a criticism
of Pacific Rim - that like the story
starts to get in the way and so when I
was watching rampage I was like oh cool
they kind of did in enough science at
least for a little while I felt like
they did enough trying to ground this in
some kind of cartoon reality that was
like cool you did a little bit of
explanation for this to make it a little
bit more real-world but there were times
where I thought they just went a little
too far with that - making it a little
too real or trying to be too heavy with
that see I get I get what you're saying
like I am all for someone's intent it's
just more of what speaking mix like how
I'm responding to what I'm actually
seeing is a different video game after a
while it did start to feel that way
where I'm like why are we spending so
much time with these humans and try to
make this a deeper movie than it needs
to be it could have been spread out
better in terms of how much we see the
monsters how much action we get because
there's a large chunk where you get like
no action and it's just human stuff and
the human stuff is nowhere near as
intriguing as the monster stuff and the
monster stuff includes the rock talking
with George in terms of video game film
like I guess I'm thinking about the last
Tomb Raider that just came out did you
feel like that was too much story no but
that's a different type of human
dramatic Asian if that's about humans
and I showed up to watch silly giant
monsters kill each other no no the
issues the world the issues not with
what they wanted to include the issue I
had is the tone that's where I felt like
the tone was inconsistent because there
were so many times where every one of
the theater was laughing I'm like I can
tell you're trying to be serious right
now there are plenty of times where it's
like oh that's very intentional like I
think the villains get a lot of good I
was just about to say because I think
they were comical and I don't think they
were supposed to be see that's where we
got confusing because there were times
where I was like oh they're definitely
comical and the rest I was like oh yeah
for me it felt like they I don't know if
they were directed that way or if they
didn't truly buy into the film that they
were a part of but they paid they they
really didn't gel with everybody else
everybody else believed the film they're
in the rock Naomi Harris
medium Jeffrey Dean Morgan good guy
Meegan's yeah everybody was so committed
to like saving the city these two were
just like caricatures of like boris and
Natasha throw a twinkle I mean they're
so bizarre like I was like what is
happening that's why the tone what it
kept kept annoying me in the opening of
this movie it's like serious like yeah
the prologue is yes serious hands and
then suddenly they'll have [ __ ] that's
like super goofy yeah but then what
we're really serious again oh now we're
goofy it was kind of a roller coaster of
goofy with seriousness I'm the kind of
guy that can throw a logic way out the
window when it comes to a movie like
this but when you have enough scenes
where you clearly want to be taken more
seriously then I start to apply logic
and rationalization to certain character
choices and reactions that occur in the
finale of this movie that we can't get
into because it would spoil it I mean
you're admitting that they were trying
to be a more than just some video game a
lot of people that we were talking with
afterwards who felt similar but there's
a lot of people who felt the same way
you did which is I'm not I just had a
really fun time I said for me the fun
was really up and down you know I would
go from having fun to not having fun and
kind of bored to having fun and then
okay I'm bored again and then the finale
is like fun okay but this now is going
on way too long
essentially my adventure with this movie
was just a big roller coaster of having
fun and then really bored like it was
just a mismatch of that I think overall
if you see a trailer for this movie what
you're looking for you will get and even
if it's unintentionally bad at times
it's still fun because of that yeah it's
still like schlocky in that way yeah
yeah I think that's what left me with
with an ultimate sense of better will
than not is like most of the movie
played to me like a live-action cartoon
and you know a good amount of the time
that was fun there were times when it
kind of started to drag
I was like okay I get it let's clip this
along but overall I mean if you can get
down with a popcorn cartoon in the
theaters at The Rock then then I can't
see why you wouldn't enjoy some of this
anyway it's a Kourtney's right I think
it's fun mmm yeah this is a serious
movie this is next all right guys well
that's our non-spoiler review of rampage
I do feel weirdly compelled to do a
spoiler talk of this video passionate
passionate bees rampage and how you
should handle these kind of movies
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell check us out on
patreon more importantly follow our good
friend Courtney Scott write on Twitter
and Instagram links to her social media
in the description box she posts
regularly and that's all she cares about
in her life as her social media so make
sure to follow her as soon as possible
help her deal with her social media
addiction thank you